[Music]
hello my name is mia wood i am a
professor of philosophy and a writer at
lab roots welcome to
lab roots is the life of her mind an
interview series dedicated to
learning how women think about their
research their field and their future
let's get started
in our inaugural conversation we are
speaking with alice drager phd
dr drager is an historian and
philosopher of science a journalist and
an activist one of those rare thinkers
who draws her readers into complex and
controversial topics as if they're just
hanging out drawing over a couple of
drinks
drager's work makes people question
long-held scientific doctrine in doing
so she forces them to consider that
these beliefs may just be rooted in
political or personal bias
trained in the history
uh and philosophy of science dr drager
is the author of four books editor of
five
many many articles and even many more
talks
her work reveals a fascinating composite
combination
of serious scholar old school muckraker
and prodigious instigator
on modern day socrates
indeed drager is unafraid to ask how and
why people believe what they do
she is also
very funny
that's very kind of you
true
um so how does uh alice drager's mind
work well let's ask her
hello allison welcome
thanks mia thank you so much for being
here
um
we appreciate you making time to chat
so let's get started um in your third
book galileo's middle finger you
mentioned that you came to your
scholarly area of expertise a bit by
accident
your dissertation advisor suggested the
topic how did that happen and
maybe more importantly what got you
excited enough about it to stick with it
through the process
sure so when i went to graduate school i
was already interested in issues of
gender and issues of science and
the gender interest came out of feminism
which i had learned chiefly from my
mother
who had a very
sort of second wave feminist approach to
the world of sort of recognizing the
ways in which women were subject to
sexism
that held them back and my interest in
science had also been long-standing and
also supported by my parents but i had
actually
gone to
undergraduate at georgetown university
for a year
and was double majoring in science and
english biology and english and was very
burned out i was a high achieving
student and i was really burned out i
was having an affair with a teacher and
from my high school who had started
using me for sex years before and i was
just burned out
so i quit school and got away from that
guy and became a mortgage broker on long
island for five years
and during that period i ended up
finishing my degree at the st university
of new york down the street which was
old westbury while still doing mortgage
brokering all day long
and
my therapist that i started seeing told
me at one point you're cured get out of
new york
so
i applied to indiana university because
my dissertation director i'm sorry my
undergraduate advisor had gotten his phd
there and uh said well you're interested
in both gender and science and
philosophy and history so this seems
like a good program for you
so my dissertation director i actually
had two but the one who suggested the
topic to me was fred churchill who was a
historian of embryology and fred
knew that i was interested in gender and
science and so he said to me well why
don't you look at the history of
hermaphroditism because nobody had
looked at that and since he was a
historian of embryology i thought okay
i'll look at embryology i thought i
would look at darwin's barnacles because
those were hermaphroditic what did
darwin think about that but fred kept
saying you should look at medicine and i
was like why it doesn't happen in humans
past the embryonic stage so
then i took another class with gene
peterson in the history department in
victorian medicine and i was interested
in still hermaphroditism and gene said
you should really look at medicine i was
like why
so finally i opened the grade catalogs
of 19th century medicine the index
catalog of the library the surgeon
general of the united states which is
the precursor to what people now know as
pubmed or medline
there are hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of human case studies i was
like okay how could it possibly be that
at age whatever i was 24 25 i've never
heard of this that doesn't make any
sense to me
so i was convinced it had been
suppressed and anything that is
suppressed is very interesting so why
had all this knowledge of human
intersect what we now call intersex
conditions been suppressed so
i decided to tackle this for my
dissertation and i was very it was easy
to be excited about it because it was a
topic that had in fact been suppressed
in the public knowledge
um and yet there was this entire secret
medical literature about it
so i
started pulling all of the cases that i
could in the 19th century in france and
britain for reasons we could talk about
if you want basically there were two
places i felt like going for my
dissertation research so
and also i could read french and i could
read english and so that worked but also
france and england were both interesting
places in terms of the development of
science and medicine at that time
so i ended up
finding a sort of natural starting point
which was 1848 for reasons we can talk
about if you want to 1914
and polled about a little over 300 cases
and
created large databases which most
historians weren't doing at that time
and still are not doing i had developed
a database for my mortgage brokering
work that allowed me to figure out how
to track refinances more efficiently in
our office
we used a program called db3 database 3.
so i used that same program to create
databases about all the cases i was
reading about i tracked where were they
showing up who were they which doctors
were seeing them what did the doctors
think what did they say about the
breasts or the clitoris or the penis or
whatever it was i just tracked it all
and i had these huge notebooks on dot
matrix because back then all the
printers were dot matrix dot matrix
paper that took up you know half of my
living room and i was just super excited
about it because it was incredibly
interesting topic so i had no trouble
staying uh attuned to it um and got my i
actually got my dissertation done in
about two years which was considered a
very fast period of time to get a
history dissertation done but i mean i
type fast and i research hard and so it
was not too difficult for me to do
i didn't know about
people like wait i so in some of the um
talks that you've given that i've seen
you know on youtube you've said um
you know you've made comments about how
uh committed uh researchers should be to
to the data but it didn't occur to me i
don't know if i just didn't know or you
haven't said that you had developed you
adapted
a database that you developed while you
were a mortgage broker that's amazing
can you say
how does that like how did that occur to
you well you know i mean i was doing a
degree in history and philosophy of
science and so of course we were
studying philosophy of science and so we
were talking a lot about data and data
analysis and letting the data talk to
you instead of you you know talking to
the data
so it seemed obvious to me that one
thing that i could do was to try to
quantify to some degree what i was
looking at to try part of what i was
interested in is the question of whether
or not
the number of reports was going up over
time which it was and where was it going
up over time and what kinds of things
were doctors interested in because
the sex of the body is all over the body
right it's it's on the feet the feet are
sexed to some degree the hips the
breasts so what were they interested in
in terms of the location of their their
fascination um and so it seemed to me
kind of an obvious thing to do although
i have to say that my dissertation
committee was like what the hell are you
doing because they had not experienced
although my second i had two
dissertation directors because one was
fred churchill in history of science and
the other one was ann carmichael in the
history of medicine and it was important
because i was bridging those two to have
two dissertation directors i was very
fortunate to have two excellent
directors
and
ended up using um computer software to
map the her interest was in the uh the
plague during the middle ages
and so she used uh or maybe it was the
renaissance i apologize i can't quite
remember which period she was studying
but she was using
mapping databases to try to figure out
how the plague had broken out and what
happened who died where did they die so
ann was kind of coming at that out of
epidemiology and i sort of had the same
sense of like well we could take a sort
of you know scientific approach to this
to some degree and try to figure it out
so i see history as a social science and
that's an example of using
sort of a
more scientific more quantitative kind
of approach to
textual analysis
and the
the i don't know if i should call it the
overlay or the underpinning
but
the
what i the philosophical disposition
right that that you
uh use
in these in that project and then your
your subsequent projects
seems
clear which is
okay
what am i bringing to the table to
interpret the data
um you know what's the the the scope of
knowledge what sorts of questions should
i ask so that i can get the you know the
right answers um
do you
when when when your advisors asked you
know what the heck or your committee
asked what the heck was going on
did how did you approach answering that
did you basically say okay well i'm
taking this disposition to to the
project where i'm asking these sorts of
questions and this is
what i'm hoping to find or i didn't know
what i was hoping to find but this is
what i did find
yeah they weren't just because they
weren't upset with what i was doing they
were just baffled and so i showed them
the notebooks i showed them these
binders that i had in which basically i
had sorted by different um so these are
spreadsheets right to some degree and i
was sorting according to different
possibilities so i could for example
sort out what had been said about
breasts in france versus britain and be
able to understand the difference in how
they were understanding breast tissue as
a sexed tissue
and so i showed them all this stuff and
i showed them for example how i could
track
certain individuals who were patients
through time in the medical literature
because it i had plugged in their the
information the doctor had given us
about where were they born what was
their profession what were their
initials so that even though they
weren't named in the medical literature
i could have a high degree of confidence
that i was actually tracking the same
person and that would be really
interesting because tracking the same
person meant getting different doctors
viewpoints of that person
so when i showed them what i was doing
they were like oh yeah this makes total
sense and you're gonna find far more
things than if you just did a you know a
hand-picking analysis and said i'm just
going to pull a few of these and pick
the most interesting ones and talk about
the most interesting ones i mean i think
part of what bothered me
was the habit at that time among
postmodern
philosophers
and literary critics to
cherry-pick texts
and
i was somebody who really felt like if
we were going to understand history we
really couldn't cherry-pick the texts we
really had to know what what was the
range out there and then what were what
was really going on in terms of the
thinking so i was not interested in
trying to take a single text and you
know
do a very intense deconstructive
analysis on a single text i was really
interested in the question of how is the
profession shifting with regard to
having to face the reality of sex
blurring and this was a time where in
the late 19th century where women were
challenging sex borders where people we
would now call gay and lesbian were
challenging sex borders and saying that
they should not be subject to
restrictions on their lives
and so it was a time when people were
pressing the boundaries that had existed
for a long time culturally
and doctors tended to be conservative
men and so they were not interested in
having those borders pushed so i was
really fascinated with the question of
how did they manage
their own political needs in the face of
this biological reality
so
do you
so so i know the history is long um
do you think that for the average either
well clinician or researcher
um that history is sort of too
um
big to wrap their arms around to make
sense in the way that
that you did with this topic or is it
just that there's not so much interest
in doing that by and large or it's not
part of medical school training
well i i mean if you're interested in
specific stuff that i found i wrote what
i think is a very readable book um
called hermaphrodites in the medical
invention of sex which is my
dissertation basically cleaned up and
made into a book
and that book very specifically is
designed for an intelligent general
readership and actually the book has
done incredibly well i mean i still get
royalties over it for
20 20 years later 25 years later i'm
still getting some royalties not a huge
amount but you know enough to buy me
some dinners every year
so um i like to think that's because the
book is indeed readable and
basically what i showed in the book was
that what physicians and scientists did
at this point when they were faced with
this very uncomfortable
biological reality that sex was very
very complicated was they came up with a
whole bunch of
techniques to organize them
theoretically so that you could pretend
that there was no threat to the social
order and they
used all sorts of categorization systems
and then later they used surgeries to
try to make sure that everybody fit into
a simple male or female category
socially so that there would not be a
social disruption because they recognize
the potential for social disruption of
the biological reality
the um in fact your ted talk
was my introduction
to your work i was working in a um uh
bioethics is not my area but it was hey
do this course it's like okay
and um so so we were we were talking
about um
identity issues and uh that talk is just
fascinating that talk grew out of the
work that you did for your dissertation
that subsequently became the book is
that
it did although then you know after so
when i started publishing my work i was
publishing it journal articles as is
typical and the first piece i published
was in a journal called victorian
studies um
and i forget what it was called um but
what happened was p the the internet was
relatively new and email was relatively
new but people who had themselves been
born with the conditions i was writing
about had started the intersex rights
movement
um and they found me and started writing
to me on email and that was kind of
surprising to me because i hadn't really
thought about the fact that of course
there are people with the same
conditions i just thought of myself as
doing dead people i don't do living
people so it didn't occur to me that
living people with the same conditions
would write and contact me and ask me to
join the movement
but that did happen and i did end up
joining the intersex rights movement so
the ted talk that you saw is as much
informed by
many years of working in the intersex
rights movement and ultimately i became
one of the leaders of the intersex
rights movement internationally um and
agitated for many years for change in
medical practice and social treatment of
people born with intersex conditions
when did you or and how did you make the
decision to um
to
so you were you were in a tenured
position at michigan state
um or up for tenure forgive me i can't
remember which it was um but
you
left that position which a lot of
researchers would
would think is either incredibly brave
or incredibly crazy but you decided to
leave that you went to uh northwestern
for a part-time position but so that you
could presumably you could devote more
time to
the work in activism how did that happen
why did you make that choice
yeah so um
i started the job at michigan state i
graduated in 95 i did a
year of
postgraduate faculty position sabbatical
replacement for john beatty who's a
historian of biology at university of
minnesota for a year and then i got a
tenure track position at michigan state
and i started the job at michigan state
in 96
and i got early tenure
i think in my fifth year i was awarded
tenure
and um
after that i got pregnant or maybe
before that i can't remember but anyway
i had a son and he was born in the year
2000 and
what ended up happening was that by that
point my
advocacy work in the intersex movement
was going full throttle i was president
of the board of the intersex society of
north america giving lots of talks doing
lots of activism work i was also
maintaining a traditional academic
career so i was researching academic
articles publishing them giving academic
talks
also teaching classes also doing
community service work um also doing
journal editorship kind of work at the
you know lower level and all of that
stuff
and so i had both of those things going
and i had a child and
um
i need a lot of sleep and um my son did
not really start sleeping through the
night until he was about two and a half
um
and so it was extremely difficult for me
to maintain that life and
i had actually always wanted to be a
writer primarily not to be a historian
or an activist or anything like that i
had always been interested in writing
and my fourth grade teacher had told me
that wasn't a real job and so i'd have
to find some other job
so
i had always spent my life sort of in
this approach avoidance attitude towards
writing as a profession um but obviously
i really love writing my books are all
written as though they're written by a
person who wants to be a writer and
it turns out you know i i did become a
writer so when i
was facing the problem of lack of sleep
and
overwhelming activist career plus an
overwhelming
[Music]
academic career
i made a list of what i enjoyed and what
i didn't enjoy and what i really enjoyed
which surprised me was being with my son
i was shocked at how much i enjoyed
being a mother i did not expect that of
myself i mean i intentionally had a
child with a man i intentionally chose
for being the father of that child but i
was still very surprised at how much my
brain reoriented towards wanting to be
with my kid
and having him go to daycare for long
periods was upsetting to me because i
felt like i was being cheated out of an
opportunity to experience that
relationship with him and watching him
grow child development is incredibly
interesting especially when it's your
own kid
and once he started talking he was very
very interesting to me
and i found myself less inclined to take
care of other people's kids i had been a
very um intense teacher i won the my
department's teaching award which was
awarded by the students every year seven
years in a row a row because i was a
very devoted very active teacher but
that was because i was giving all that
maternal energy to them and when i had
my own kid my maternal sense really did
shift
and so i made the list of what i enjoyed
and what i didn't enjoy my son was on
there and writing was right up there but
i was having less and less time to do
writing and what i didn't enjoy was my
job i didn't enjoy the committee work i
did enjoy teaching but i hated grading
hated it hated teaching writing to
freshmen even though i was good at it i
hated doing it because i was a
professional writer who did not want to
keep t this is like if you had somebody
who's a professional ice skater having
to teach somebody to just put on their
skates every day it's exhausting to do
that so i said to my spouse i think i
want to give up tenure and become an
independent and do writing and do the
activism but mostly get more sleep and
be with the kid and have a more sane
life and he said well why don't you
think about it a little longer because
that's a really big decision and he's
very conventional this is how we've
operated he's very conventional i'm very
unconventional so we feed off of each
other that way
i
mentioned it to my mother-in-law who
thought it was a great idea i quit your
job mention it to my mother who said
absolutely do it you'll only get one
chance to experience you know you may
have another kid but you're only going
to have a chance once or twice to
experience motherhood and she said it's
worth it do it and also having more time
for writing was important so i
tried talking michigan state into a
part-time job and i tried again and
again and they wouldn't take me
seriously um
and i said so finally i submitted a
letter of resignation which simply said
this has been great thank you i'm
leaving and they said wait wait wait
wait wait no we'll help you figure this
out
and i was like look i asked you for like
a year to help me figure this out and
you gave me no assistance whatsoever so
goodbye
so i left and they were shocked they
were genuinely shocked they never really
thought i would leave um
and then some friends of mine at
northwestern called me up and were like
we're putting together a program and
they there was the program in medical
humanities bioethics we're putting
together a master's program we need
somebody to teach the history of science
the history of medicine course
so i actually at first they they didn't
have the master's program at first they
just asked me would i like to teach a
seminar for them in their program and i
enjoyed that very much teaching medical
students was really fun and then i
became the teacher of the history
medicine class in the master's program
and most people from the outside thought
i had a full-time full professorship
because i was promoted to full professor
fairly quickly at northwestern but it
was always a part-time adjunct position
and most people just didn't know that i
didn't broadcast that it didn't pay very
well they refused to give me retirement
i had to fight like hell i think i got
one year of retirement out of them
um it was very frustrating in terms of
the treatment by the top administration
but the middle administration treated me
very well and
my department was full of lovely people
who i loved working with and i loved
working with the medical students so i
commuted to chicago
220 miles each way
and i taught in the winter quarter which
was january to march which is not the
best time to be going around lake
michigan i have to say
but for 10 years i did that and uh
my son and i and my husband built a
schedule around that so that i could go
every week for 10 weeks in a row and
otherwise i did most of the stuff
remotely and which you know nowadays we
all know how to do that but i learned
how to do that very early and if there
was a huge snow i taught my class
remotely they were in the seminar room
and they stuck me at the end of the
table and
we had a remote conversation
so um that was before zoom it was just
me at the end of the table and i forgot
what what software we used back then to
do that but
i did that for 10 years and then
my dean censored some work that i
published that i had not written but i
had edited and published in a journal
that our department put out and i tried
to change the censorship for over a year
and got nowhere so a colleague of mine
kristy kirschner and i both quit the
department over the censorship and i've
not been in an academic position since
except that i do give a lot of academic
talks and i occasionally have a week on
somebody's campus because they'll invite
me to be a presidential this or that and
i go for a week and get to enjoy
being back on a campus for a week
do you mind my asking about
sort of in
connection with the uh experiences that
you had with administration you detail
for example the the journal atrium the
experience with
the
university kind of um giving over um the
the domain of the of the journal to uh
the hospital that was taking over the
the medical center um and that that they
kind of had a brand that they wanted to
promote and
the article that you had one of the
articles that you had solicited had been
read by the dean i believe and and
um rub that person the wrong way no pun
intended and so that's what set off that
um what eventually led you to resign but
can you say
if i've got my facts right can you say a
little bit about i know it's not
directly on the
questions that i that i was thinking
about um asking but
the connection between
the importance of the concept of
academic freedom which i think a lot of
people including some academics seem to
misunderstand right
academic freedom and
um
doing really good
scholarly work that benefits you know a
well-informed citizenry
yeah so it wasn't that the hospital
bought the domain but but the hospital
and the medical school came to a
kind of agreement and it was a secret
agreement because it's a northwestern is
a private medical school in northwestern
hospitals a private hospital so we
couldn't see the agreements but
basically i was told that the dean's
concern was over the branding agreement
between the hospital and the medical
school and the article that was
published was a article called head
nurses which was by bill peace who was a
cultural anthropologist and disability
studies scholar and bill was writing
about his own experience at the age of
18 of becoming spinal cord disabled and
a nurse who gave him
oral sex to reassure him that his sex
life would continue on and they were
friends they had known each other for
months
and she was doing it out of a place of
compassion while he was in a long-term
rehabilitation facility
and he was not writing to suggest that
this is what should happen today he was
writing to talk about what he called the
wild west days of rehabilitation
medicine which to me is a historian of
medicine and a historian of sexuality
was really interesting because it was a
really interesting period in the 1970s
the 1970s was a period of
experimentation with drugs
experimentation with sex and that stuff
leaked into the rehabilitation hospitals
people were doing drugs and having sex
and so
it was a particularly interesting period
from
as a historian of medicine so i thought
it was a really well written piece and
super interesting and bill did raise the
question of like do we take care of the
sexual needs of people with disability
today and he didn't mean like literally
you know do we give them sexual
opportunities but rather do we pay
attention to the fact that they want to
have sex in the future
and so i thought his piece was excellent
as did my colleagues and um
i think the only thing that um one of
them suggested was that the title should
be in quotation mark
because the title was head nurse
which was a joke um
but but there were other frankly very
intense pieces in that in that
particular issue every issue of the
journal aging was very intense on
purpose this is a very hard-hitting
medical humanities journal that was made
us all uncomfortable all the time um all
the time and this particular issue was
the one i got to edit the
theme that the group came up with was
bad girls and
so there were several pieces in there on
abortion that i thought were actually
the ones that were going to get us in
trouble i thought the piece that was
written by sorry forgetting her name but
it was a person who does women's studies
and she's also an ob gyn and she was
writing about doing abortions as women's
work and she was talking about the fact
that she found that the light boxes from
bed bath and beyond are actually the
most useful ones for taking out the
products of conception and looking at it
to make sure that she'd gotten
everything out of the uterus
and you know that made me uncomfortable
that had me squirming the idea of using
stuff from bed bath to be on to do
abortions was had me squirming so i
thought that was if i got in trouble for
anything it was gonna be that one but it
wasn't that one apparently a couple of
catholic nurses complained about the
piece by bill peace
i'm sure they also were upset about
pieces about transgender life and about
women's sports and about abortion and
everything else but
um you know i was told shut up don't
talk about it the dean ordered um
dean eric nielsen who's still the dean
of northwestern's medical school ordered
that bill's piece be taken down offline
he couldn't withdraw the paper copies
that had already been sent out but this
was this was censorship this was not
people say you know well it's not really
censorship because he didn't take it
back but he did he literally censored
the piece and withdrew it
and to the credit of the people in my
department they basically took down all
of atrium at that point because they
said you know you're not going to take
down one thing and not all of it
but we were kind of told you know shut
up let's try to work this out and i did
i kept my mouth shut for over a year in
terms of not
challenging it and finally um you know i
had galley's middle finger was coming
out and it's a book about academic
freedom it's a book that encourages
people to
do controversial work to do
cutting-edge stuff and go where they
need to go in terms of the questions and
the answers and i went to the
deans i made an appointment with them
and i said you know here are the blurbs
about the book these important people
blurbing about the importance of
academic freedom i cannot be a hypocrite
i can't i can't put up with your
censorship of this work so it's me or
you basically like you gotta change or i
gotta leave
and they said you know thank you for
your input
and then i tried the provost dan lenzer
at the time
of northwestern and basically said the
same thing like damn you know like you
gotta you gonna fix this or not and he
didn't
so um kristy kirchner my colleague quit
and i quit both over the censorship and
we went very public with it because we
thought people should know what had
happened that basically and this was
particularly ironic because bill's
pieces article was about how the fact
that people with disabilities have their
sex lives censored and that's exactly
what happened with this article was his
sex life was censored so it was
outrageous and we made a big deal of it
and
you know i could have gone and looked
for other academic jobs at that point
but i was so bitter
from that experience and i also didn't
want people thinking i'd done it as a
publicity stunt or an attempt to get to
a different um university
so i just told people you know that i
needed to do something else for a while
and i did do that and i've not gone back
in part because of having watched things
my my spouse is now the dean of michigan
state's medical school
and when he was being appointed he asked
me if i wanted to pursue a spousal hire
back at michigan state
you know michigan state is a fine
university but
honestly the way that things are
happening in academia today i think i
would last about a week this problem
that you've
talked about concentrated in
higher education
and all the
avenues of research within higher
education
is strikes me as sort of a a microcosm
for
so much that's going on you know in the
world which makes me think that
there's um in addition to the point that
that you've made about resiliency
there
may or may be part and parcel of that is
just um and and a lack of
skill associated with
um
listening
assessing problems assessing evidence
assessing what counts as evidence and
what the appropriate evidence is and so
forth
that's
that's everywhere
um but it seems particularly concerning
in
the research arms of higher education
when so much you know of discovery and
innovation let's say particularly within
the physical sciences right
is happening there
so i know you've had some experiences
with
uh colleagues in in the sciences um
running into problems with with with
effectively straw man arguments against
their work right complete distortions of
their work and then they get sort of
pushed aside
marginalized or otherwise just pushed
off the page um
do you see that like so i guess
my my question is
um
what sorts of tools do you think
the the the researcher whether they're a
scientist a physical scientist or
otherwise what tools does the researcher
need
in order to follow the evidence oops you
froze could you say the question again
sorry what sorts of tools do you think
that the that any researcher needs
in order to follow the evidence where it
leads in order to have the open mind to
consider that they might be wrong for
example well it's very hard i mean we we
become emotionally invested in the
things that we study and it's inevitable
that we become emotionally invested in
them because that's what keeps us going
right it's the passion for the work and
so
you know all of the things that we've
set up in modern science tends to help
things like peer review things like
repeatability expectations but of course
some of that fails we've had the great
repeatability
crisis in psychology for example where
people go out and they do a single study
and it's very exciting and everybody
says oh that's very interesting and
nobody repeats it and finds out it
doesn't hold
peer review is obviously quite
challenging in the sense that it's
always politicized
um inevitably even if we try not to make
it that way so
you know i think
one of the things that has to happen is
there have to be certain checks and
balances on the system um
just one example would be retraction
watch which i'm a huge fan of and a
donor to is a
news organization that basically tracks
retractions within the scientific
literature and uses that as a window
into looking at misconduct but also
looking at whether or not the
self-correcting systems of science are
really working so they recently talked
about a guy who retracted his own papers
because he redid an analysis and
realized he got some numbers totally
wrong
and sort of lauded him as a hero and i
don't disagree although he said i'm just
doing what we should all do right which
is retract our work when we discover
that there's an error but it's weird how
rarely that happens that people admit
errors in their work so you know i think
we have to really
acknowledge that if we're doing work
that's really good that sometimes it's
going to involve an ego bruising
and
when i go through that when i have to
correct something i've done
i actually had a weird little thrill
from it because i think oh i'm part of a
system that's correcting and it's very
exciting and i wish we could i wish we
could get more people to feel that way
that when you know the first feeling my
god is oh man i screwed up and you know
it feels sad and it makes me like
and then i have to do the work and see
did i screw it up how did i screw it up
and then if i did and i have to do a
correction of it then then i do get this
sort of weird little high where i'm like
well you know what that i'm human and
i should have the humility to do
corrections and that's a good thing so
it feels kind of good but i don't think
we convey that enough
i really do wish that every
class in colleges and universities today
would deal with questions of reason and
evidence and it troubles me that a lot
of them don't engage that that they're
doing
in the case of the humanities sometimes
a lot of incredibly sloppy teaching
which is just about low level sort of
political text analysis
and
on the sciences side just conveyance of
facts which is really not teaching you
how to think so i wish every college and
university class today would engage
especially undergraduates but also
graduate students in questions of reason
and evidence all the time i mean i think
the way that we got to january 6th and
we got to
the problems we have today are not just
caused by the college university level
but there's some hope there of helping
to correct things
and and at first thank you so much for
the being so generous with your time
there's so much that i want to ask you
but i don't want to impose too much so
um
the
so you talked a little bit about
um the process that you go through when
you think you may have made you know
made a mistake
um
do you think that the
um
the process i mean so the specific
details of the process would probably be
different from one discipline to the
next but
the sort of the process
of
revisiting your work
is similar um across
your disciplines and if i understand
correct well i think of you as being you
know you're you're a journalist you're
um
a popular philosopher or you do public
philosophy i should say um
uh obviously you're an historian uh of
medical science and you're an historian
of science
do you see there there being a process
that that's similar across those
uh disciplines
yeah i mean i think i'm less of a
historian these days than i used to be
um more of a journalist so so in 2014 i
founded a newspaper for the people of
east lansing called east lansing info
and so i ended up doing not just
journalism at the national level which i
also did because i ended up having to do
journalism to help advance um
information about intersex and what was
going on with intersex care but also in
addition to that um i founded a local
newspaper so what i would say is that i
mean the process is very similar in
terms of we're looking for evidence
we're trying not to impose our own point
of view that said anytime you're asking
a question you're narrowing the data
that you're looking for so there's
always that issue
is me too
the the
some of the other um
uh issues with which you you've been
involved so for example um you
were brought back to
um
the intersex issue
when
and forgive me maybe you can you'll tell
the story but um
it was brought to your attention that
that a researcher a clinician and
researcher was using dexamethasone
um
i i guess purportedly to try to prevent
uh intersex babies
and
um it seems to me and unless i miss the
the way the story went that um
that person's work being you know
corrected was not um
i don't know i don't know if it went
under the radar if it didn't go under
the radar if it's not relevant to the
point i was making about people being
open to receiving corrections but
how did that
happen and and what's the status now
yeah so this is the story that takes up
the last third of galileo's middle
finger because
the the first third of get two-thirds of
galileo's middle finger are largely
about activists attacking scientists and
my sort of dismay over that and a lot of
people think that's all the book is
about is about how terrible it is that
activists attack scientists but the last
third of the book reminds people why
activists are very important in terms of
correcting the scientific system that
will sometimes not correct itself and it
talks about my being pulled back into
intersex advocacy
i think it was 2009 or 2010 i got calls
from friends of mine i had at that point
retired from intersex activist work
and um
they let me know that a researcher that
i knew very well um clinician researcher
in new york city maria nu who's a
pediatric endocrinologist and member of
the national academy of sciences
was using dexamethasone prenatally
dexamethasone is a steroid a lot of us
have heard about because of covid it's a
generic steroid that calms down
inflammation as well as having other
effects
and she was using it in very early
pregnancy starting it as soon as
pregnancy was acknowledged to try to
prevent
the development of intersex
characteristics in women who were at
risk of having a child with one
particular condition which is called
congenital adrenal hyperplasia or cah
in some cases of cah female fetuses can
be viralized so they can be born with
genitals that are in between male and
female or even genitals that go all the
way to the male side of the spectrum
even though they're genetic females and
have a uterus and typically uterus and
ovaries inside
so the problem with using this was not
the attempt to prevent intersex but the
way that she was talking about it which
was she was claiming it had been found
safe for mother and child when she was
selling it to the patients but then
turning around and telling the nih she
needed money to study these people
retroactively to see whether or not it
was safe or effective
so these people didn't know they were in
an experiment and this was a drug being
used with the intention of crossing the
placental barrier with the intention of
altering fetal development
seven out of eight of the fetuses
affected would by with the treatment
would not even be the type that they
meant to target the reason being only
half of the fetuses would be female half
would be male and
cah is autosomal recessive and you don't
need to know what that means to know
only one in four of the offspring of the
parents at risk would end up having this
disease
and it is a disease it's an endocrine
disease that's the intersex is a side
effect that develops because of the
disease
so only one in eight of the fetuses
would even benefit in theory according
to what she thought of his benefit from
this
intervention so seven out of eight of
the fetuses were being blasted with this
with no possibility to benefit
and
the research she had done coming out of
it was terrible i mean it was it was
just really shoddy and unable to
conclude anything basically
and there were physicians who were very
upset about what she was doing because
they felt like this was a very high risk
maneuver
and there was research at that point
coming out of sweden showing that
children had been harmed by this and um
the swedish group was taking a lot of
flack from her group and her defenders
and so i got involved in that thinking
we would just ask the federal government
to investigate because it was an
nih-funded project her retrospective
studies were nih-funded and she had some
small prospective studies to study
particular things like screen genetic
screening
and i thought that the fda would also
get involved because this was an
off-label use of the drug but more
importantly it
she was advertising the drug as safe and
effective when this was an off-label use
the fda had not said you could say this
was safer effective
so then she i mean it's a very long
story but she made the claim that the
fda had said it was safe and effective
which was this outrageous lie
you know that she could not prove she
had a letter which vaguely said one
thing from a doctor from years ago but
absolutely not the case that this is fda
approved by any means no less the fda
approving advertising is safe and
effective i thought this was so
completely outrageous that the
government would absolutely act and
instead i was set up
as i explained in the book the people
who managed to get the investigation
assigned to them were people who were
allies of hers
and
when they came out with their report
basically saying that i was wrong and at
the same time one of their side groups
published a paper calling me deeply
unethical for having brought all this
forward they published both on the same
day and i didn't realize they were
associated so i thought i had been
proved
you know unethical and wrong and i
nearly killed myself and that that's in
the book although it's alluded to sort
of vaguely about a break in my brain
and it took a long time to recover from
that and
you know the recovery largely involved
my spouse and my best friend ellen
feeder who was one of the people who had
worked on the
petitions to the government with me
telling me over and over again nothing
we found was wrong
their conclusion is wrong you're not
wrong
so
i spent the next two years researching
everything i could about this and um
demanded all the
grant reports and everything out of the
through the freedom of information act
which the fda and the office for human
research protections refused to give to
me it didn't even refuse didn't even
acknowledge my requests simply ignored
me
so i sued them
and the suit led to them having to
release the material to me
and i got the material and i put
together the truth of what happened
which was i was right that we were right
and we were not only right we were
horrifyingly right that there was
that cornell
knew about what was going on and didn't
do anything about it basically um and in
fact cornell had been hit with a four
million dollar fine at one point because
an internal whistleblower had blown the
whistle and it turned out that
whistleblowing was about partly about
what i had found so
so it was a huge um
very scary situation both for the women
and the children who were subjected to
these lies and um made to go through
these treatments but also for me
personally because
it they really came after me they didn't
want the particular group of people
didn't want me saying that what had
happened was a huge ethical travesty
and um as it turns out you know
when you ask what's happening with
xmithinson today i can't figure it out
it's very unclear to me she seems to
have been retired finally um which is
not surprising because she'd be 90 years
old now or
something like yeah close to 90 or over
90 years old um but
and
it does not appear that
people are openly advertising this use
the endocrine groups came out with
strong cautions against using it in any
form other than a fully
vetted fully consented experimental
system where women absolutely knew the
truth about what they were signing up
for which i don't think a lot of women
frankly would sign up for it if they
knew the truth
but that said
we've had covid now and a very common
treatment for covet is dexamethasone and
a lot of pregnant women have been given
dexamethasone and i keep saying to my
spouse is anybody tracking what's
happening to the fetuses being exposed
to dexamethasone because i would love to
know what the heck's happening there the
other thing that's happened is i
reported it in the atlantic
i found out by accident that some ivf
doctors have been giving dexamethasone
to women claiming it prevents
miscarriage which is completely a lie
there's no evidence whatsoever the
dexamethasone prevents miscarriage but
it's been given out like candy
on i think on the basis of maria news
claims that it's been found safe and
effective because basically she went out
and
made this claim in the literature over
and over again until people simply
believe it if you make a claim over and
over again
and you just cite yourself people assume
you're telling the truth
and
it's a it's a case it
it killed me because i couldn't find
reporters willing to write about it
because it was a complex case and most
reporters today because of the way the
internet has destroyed the investigative
journalism establishment they don't have
time to deal with it and so it's been
very very hard to get it into
newspapers and that's part of why i
became a journalist was so that i could
start reporting what i was finding about
dexamethasone and start alerting people
to it
because it is so upsetting
will you so so
it sounds to me tell me if i'm wrong
like you've got the material for
your next book
they actually given what you've just
said about the prevalence of
dexamethasone during covid and tracking
and so forth um what
those findings might be
and
retroactively
um
what we should be thinking about the
original um conflict right between
saying that the
drug was safe off label but working the
study that's determining safety right
all of that seems like it it would make
for a really fascinating read
yeah i i really think that that question
of what's happening with dexamethasone
in the population treated with covet is
going to have to be something
epidemiologists study because that's
really an epidemiological question um
you know and i was drawing on their work
when i was trying to figure out what
happened to this population
no i think
well the the book proposal i have now
that my agent's working on um placing is
actually about storytelling and about
the importance of storytelling to human
survival which comes out of all of this
work in part
not so much the prenatal dexamethasone
but the the issue of the ways in which
we have a totally broken now
storytelling system
um but i have instead thought about
doing a book about um
having done local news for almost 10
years and the experience of
being within journalism and the ways in
which the media system looks when you're
inside of it because
it really is very different than most
people think you know people have this
sort of good or evil view of the media
and it's far more complicated than that
it's very very similar to the sciences
in terms of having a theoretical
devotion to facts but the question is
where the rubber meets the road and
there are some people who are in fact
very dedicated to that process but there
are other people who as we know
wear the
costume and then just make stuff up
and that happens in all sorts of areas
so the kinds of checks and balances
systems that are important in the
sciences are exactly the same as those
that are important in the new system and
i think that would be a very interesting
book but to be honest i'm about to
release
my first uh murder mystery over the last
several years i've been writing murder
mysteries to give myself psychological
relief so my first
book is i'm going to serialize it so
people can read it for free and give me
feedback to drive up interest in it but
it's called the index case and it will
be released soon it will also be
released on paper you'll be able to buy
it i'm self-publishing it because i
frankly didn't want to deal with the
publishing industry on this because i've
so enjoyed writing them i
i've had friends of mine editing them
and
giving me feedback and i'm currently
writing the fourth book in the series
but none of them have been released yet
um i've been doing that privately for my
own sake well count me in because
a huge mystery fan i read mysteries from
everywhere in the world
i'll send you one for sure yeah yeah
yeah and i'll buy them when they come
out but yeah absolutely so okay so
um
when i was at i was that my last
question was going to be so what's next
thank you for for telling us so
you're placing a book now
um you're getting ready to release uh
the mystery series and
potentially uh the um
uh now i'm gonna mispronounce it
why the word escaped me death
not example dexamethasone
uh and the uh book on journalism so
we'll look over hopefully yes and i have
a podcast that's about to be released
that is called just answer the question
and uh
that is uh highly produced um so it's
not your sort of you know interviewing
one person thing which i enjoy but i
wanted to do something that was more
writerly and more compositional so my
friend mike tieger is my producer and we
have people on
around a central question like um
uh
what have i done is our first one and
then we have one on um what's it like to
play me we interviewed the women who
have played me in the narrative the oral
versions of my books so the audiobooks i
was curious what's it like to play me
um and
we also
have an episode coming up on um how
could you love a rat
because we've had pet rats but we also
talk about human rats and how do you how
do you love a human rat
um and so that's been a lot of fun
because that's been a very different
form of writing for me taking these
interviews and piecing them together and
doing an overarching narration and then
mike adds music and that's been really
really fun for me so that's been
something sort of different and then i
have a newsletter that i just started
which is available through my website
alicedragger.com
so
i'm kind of i'm non-sabbatical from the
newspaper but when i went on sabbatical
the newspaper collapsed without me so
i'm also about to share a task force of
trying to figure out how to get the
newspaper back and move that along again
um because people need local news so a
lot of the projects i'm doing now are
not academic projects because i am 56
years old and i feel like i've earned
the right to be a writer
finally after all these years so i'm
enjoying being a writer right now um and
that's been really cool yes
congratulations on all of those projects
thank you i write to think that
uh the podcast obviously
one can can access it through the
various media for that or programs for
that um but will you announce it through
alice draker.com as well we will yes we
just finished shooting a promo video for
it it's not a video podcast but we did a
promo video for it and that'll be
released with the first three episodes
quite soon mike and i are both kind of
perfect perfectionist so we've been like
fiddling with the first three episodes
to make sure we think they're perfect
but we just did an interview today for
example for the episode y run which is
uh exploration of why physically run but
also why run for office because both
mike and i are runners but we're also
interested in the question of why do
people run for office and we just
interviewed today jocelyn benson who's
the secretary of state of michigan who
was just testifying yesterday at the
select committee on the january 6th
hearings i'm a big fan of hers and we
also interviewed peter sagel for that
episode from npr's wait wait don't tell
me because he's a runner a marathoner
and uh so it's a it's a really fun
episode about why run why run for office
and why physically run and it looks at
the interplay between those two kinds of
runnings and actually the interview with
justin benson was fantastic but she
talked about marathoning as a metaphor
in her life for the kinds of work she
does to keep elections safe so it was
really really interesting so that's been
a blast for me because i get to
interview really interesting people so
i'm loving it oh i definitely want to
listen to that i i'm
i'm old so i'm slow to the podcast uh
um process but it's such a wonderful way
it's it's almost like old-time radio um
it is it's really fun yeah i will make a
point to uh to listen to your podcast
what's the name again
just answer the question
awesome yeah thank you so very much for
your time and your ex very welcome
um on behalf of uh walter my
my classroom and labyrinths dog um i
thank you so much
and um i hope that we'll be able to
catch up with you again uh when your
next book comes out sounds great thanks
mia thank you so much